ya por fin aquí tengo la tabla de la
cual te hablaba en el vídeo pasado es
justo esta que está aquí y por eso no
quise gastar tu tiempo y ya me di a la
tarea de hacerla ahora el problema dice
que si existe un evento el cual tenga
cuatro sesiones dos descansos y un
momento para la comida y este evento
acaba a las cuatro y media y además me
dan el dato de que cada sesión
voy a apuntarlo aquí cada sesión dura
una hora y media una hora y media y
además me dan el dato de que cada
descanso debe durar solamente un cuarto
de hora descanso debe durar un cuarto de
hora y que la comida la comida debe de
ser de una hora
entonces la comida es de una hora
entonces lo que me pregunta el problema
a qué hora va a iniciar este evento es
decir yo lo que quiero saber es el
inicio de la sesión 1 para resolver este
problema me di cuenta que hay dos formas
de resolverlo la primera tal vez sería
la más cotidiana sería trabajar esta
tabla hasta llenar la hora por hora
dados los datos que me dan sin embargo
también me di cuenta que hay otra forma
de resolverla mucho más fácil y creo que
mucho más rápida así que vamos a
intentarlo lo primero que quiero que te
des cuenta es que este evento va a tener
una dos tres cuatro sesiones por lo
tanto lo voy a apuntar aquí vamos a
tener cuatro sesiones y cada una de
estas sesiones dura hora y media
entonces por hora y media para ver
cuánto lo que va a durar en total todas
las cuatro sesiones por una hora y media
y esto cuando lo multiplicamos me dan
seis horas esto es seis horas en total
ok sería muy bueno que tú verificadas
que son seis horas multiplicando cuatro
por este quebrado
ahora esto es porque tenemos cuatro
sesiones pero también tenemos dos
descansos tenemos este descanso de aquí
y este descanso de camps y cada descanso
dura un cuarto de hora entonces déjenme
anotarlo aquí tenemos dos descansos
descansos y cada uno de ellos dura un
cuarto de hora entonces lo voy a
multiplicar por un cuarto dos por un
cuarto es un medio entonces de los
descansos vamos a gastar un medio de
hora muy bien y además tenemos una
comida entonces vamos a notarlo aquí una
comida una comida y por cierto esta
comida debe de durar una hora es el dato
que me dan por una hora y esto va a ser
igual a una hora entonces contando las
cuatro sesiones los dos descansos y la
comida horas horas aquí es una y si
sumamos en total lo que debe durar este
evento deben de ser seis
más un medio de hora más una hora en
total el evento debe durar siete horas y
media siete horas y media horas muy bien
ahora ya sé que este evento debe durar
siete horas y media y se además que el
evento debe de acabar a las cuatro y
media entonces si a cuatro y media le
restamos siete horas y media a qué hora
debe de empezar el evento bueno pues si
le quito 30 minutos a las 4 y media me
dan las 4 y ahora si le quito 7 horas me
van a dar las 3 las 2 la una las 12 las
11 las 10 las 9 si le restamos a las 4 y
media de la tarde voy a suponer que es
la tarde no creo que sea a las 4 y media
de la madrugada quitando las 7 horas y
media a las 4 30 de la tarde llegamos a
que el inicio de este evento debe de ser
a las 9
a las 9 am y aquí está la respuesta esta
podría ser una forma de resolver este
problema ahora también hay otra forma
muy normal que también se te podría
ocurrir para resolver este mismo
problema y sería quitarle a cada una de
las horas del fin la cantidad de tiempo
que debe durar cada uno de estas partes
de este evento la última sesión debe de
acabar a las cuatro y media pero cada
sesión debe de durar una hora y media
por lo tanto si le restamos una hora y
media a las cuatro y media de la tarde
voy a llegar a las tres de la tarde
entonces ésta debe de empezar a las tres
de la tarde ahora sí ésta empieza a las
tres de la tarde el descanso debe de
acabar a las tres de la tarde y si el
descanso acaba las tres de la tarde a
qué hora empezó bueno pues el descanso
dura un cuarto de hora entonces si le
quitamos un cuarto de hora a las tres de
la tarde voy a llegar a las 2 45 a las 2
45 de la tarde es mi último descanso
empieza mi último descanso a las 245 y
en ese momento es cuando acaba la sesión
número
entonces la sesión número 3 acaba a las
2 45 pm y si la sesión número 3 a cabo a
las 2 45 a qué hora empezó pues vamos a
quitar la hora y media a las 2 45 y
vamos a llegar a la una con 15 minutos a
la una con 15 minutos de la tarde por lo
tanto la comida debe de acabar a la una
con 15 minutos de la tarde pero la
comida duraba una hora entonces la
comunidad debe de empezar a las 12 con
15 minutos y aquí todavía estamos
hablando de la tarde es pm y por lo
tanto la sesión número 2 debe de
terminar a las 12 con 15 pm y si le
quitamos a esto una hora y media si le
quitamos a 12 horas una hora me quedan
las 11 y si a esto le quitamos 15
minutos nos van a quedar las 10 45 a las
10 45 debe de empezar la sesión número 2
pm aquí puedes verificar tu respuesta ya
casi acabamos porque aquí tenemos un
descanso y el descanso debe durar un
cuarto de hora
entonces el descanso debe de empezar a
las 1045
ahora si estamos hablando de am o
vacunos pm perdón perdón perdón es a m y
entonces 15 minutos antes fue cuando
empezó el descanso es decir a las 10 y
media a las 10 y media a m es cuando
debe de empezar el descanso y bueno la
sesión número uno debe de acabar a las
10 30am y además sabemos que dura una
hora y media entonces 10 30 m - una hora
y media me da las 9 am que por cierto es
la respuesta aquí están las dos formas
de resolver este mismo problema pero
bueno ya acabe este problema y vamos a
ver el siguiente y el siguiente problema
es el problema número 6 entonces vamos a
ver qué me dice el problema número 6 y
parece ser que no está tan difícil dice
y 2 x menos 52 x menos 5 x 1 x 1 y 3 x 8
3 x menos 8
estos son enteros y además x 1 es la
mediana este de aquí es la mediana de
estos 3 enteros y bueno recuerda que la
mediana es el número que está en medio
por ejemplo si tenemos los números 13 7
8 y 9
la mediana sería 7 porque es el número
que está justo en medio esta sería la
mediana de este equipo aquí me dicen que
x + 1 es la mediana de estos tres
enteros entonces cuál es un valor válido
para x y nos dan varios incisos con
varios valores para x entonces creo que
no hay de otra
tenemos que probar inciso x inciso vamos
a ver inciso a
x igual a 5 si x vale 5 entonces vamos a
ver qué es lo que pasa con estos números
enteros que tenemos aquí el primero
sería dos por cinco menos cinco lo cual
es 2 por 5 10 menos 5 es 5 muy bien el
segundo sería 5 más 1 lo cual es 6 muy
bien y este sería 3 por 5 menos 8 y esto
es igual 3 por 5 es 15 15 menos 8 es 7 y
del ojo tenemos mucha suerte porque es
justo este inciso aquí tenemos la
mediana
curiosamente 6 es el número que está en
medio de 5 y 7 es la mediana de este
equipo y además y además todos son
enteros entonces creo que estamos de
suerte pues nos leyeron la mente los
autores este libro además tiene toda la
lógica del mundo que lo hayan puesto con
la primera opción para que nos dieran
una pequeña guía acerca de que teníamos
que sustituir el valor de x
en estos números que tenemos aquí así
que ya está es el inciso a vamos a
movernos al siguiente problema entonces
déjame quitar esto al problema número 7
el 7 de la buena suerte un artesano está
vendiendo unas coronas decorativas en
una exposición de arte y artesanías
frase sin importancia la ganancia neta p
en pesos obtenida por la venta de las
coronas está dada por y aquí viene la
parte útil del problema p d n es igual a
0.75 0.75 n menos 50 menos 50 donde n es
la cantidad de coronas vendidas y me
preguntan cuántas coronas necesito
vender para obtener una ganancia de 100
pesos es decir lo que quiero es que pdn
la ganancia obtenida este día sea 100
pesos me va a quedar que 100 es igual
0.75 n menos 50 y bueno lo que hay que
obtener s n
entonces tenemos una ecuación de primer
grado y voy a sumar 50 de ambos lados de
la ecuación más 50 este lado y aquí más
50 de tal manera que del lado derecho
estos dos se van a cancelar y me queda
solamente 0.75 nm esto es igual a 150 a
150 y bueno de aquí voy a dividir a
ambos lados entre 0.75 entre 0.75 y aquí
entre 0.75 de tal manera que estos dos
se van a ir y me sale que n es igual a
150 entre 0.75 pero como no tengo
calculadora
voy a recordar que 0.75 es lo mismo que
tres cuartos entonces me quedan 150
entre 1 entre
cuartos y aquí tengo que hacer una ley
del sándwich tengo que multiplicar este
por este y este por este y entonces me
quedan cuatro por ciento 54 por ciento
50 entre 3 pero si yo saco tercera
arriba y tercera abajo me queda arriba
solamente 54 por 50 es 200 es decir que
tengo que vender 200 coronas para
obtener una ganancia de 100 pesos que
por cierto este es el inciso
así que ya están vamos a hacer un último
problema voy a cambiar de color y voy a
trabajar con el problema número 8 el
problema número 8 dice lo siguiente si x
cuadrada más cuadrada es igual a 73 x
cuadrada más de cuadrada es igual a 73 y
por otra parte x por james esto es igual
a 24 entonces lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale x +
elevado al cuadrado esto es lo que yo
quiero saber y bueno esto de aquí es un
binomio cuadrado perfecto esto es lo
mismo que x + james que multiplica a x +
james y hay que hacerlo cuánto es esto
hay una fórmula de hecho para calcular
este fin no me el cuadrado perfecto pero
vamos a hacerlo de una manera explícita
x por x es x cuadrada x por james me da
x y después tengo 10 x x que es lo mismo
que x y después tengo que por james lo
cual es cuadrada más de cuadrada y esto
es lo mismo que x cuadrada más 2 veces x
bien sumamos estos dos este y este más
que cuadrada y después yo sé que x
cuadrada más y cuadrada déjame cambiar
de color
este más este me dicen que es 73
entonces de esta parte tengo 73 y a esto
hay que sumarle dos veces x m pero x m
que es 24 x 24 y por lo tanto hay que
multiplicar 2 por 24 y cuántos esto pues
esto es lo mismo que 73 más 48 y esto es
lo mismo 8 y 3 11 y llevamos unam 7 y 18
y 4 son 12 121 es decir que x más
elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 121 y ya está lo único
que tuve que hacer era expandir este
binomio al cuadrado perfecto así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo